[Music]
hey guys freefall kept a million
subscribers strong subreddit for game
trans fence is usually where the leaks
leaked photos and leak plots are posted
first if it wanted season six and seven
spool you could have just gone there and
read an entire plot for yourself this
year however there are no confirmed leak
plots except for a few spoilers leaked
by freaky doctor the one about Tyrians
major betrayal and death about which I
made a video one week ago still lick
plus the often appear on this subreddit
and most of them don't gain any
popularity because it's too obvious how
fake and FEM written votes they are in
the midst of all these badly plus
there's also this one posted by Clay toy
and even though it is in my opinion also
fake leaked based on everything we know
and expect from season 8 it did gain a
lot of popularity especially because
some of the points seem to be bagged by
the official trailer and photos once
again I don't think it's real it's
probably fake fan written season 8 plot
but many does seem to think it's legit
so I decided to share it with you and
hear your take on all of it recently did
cause a small argue between the free
folk subscribers who think it's legit
who think it might be real and who like
me believe it's fake I would not even
bother sharing it since I personally
don't think it's legit but since its
gained quite a bit of popularity and
since many think it's fake I'll leave it
on you to decide whether you believe it
or not so once again before we start
reading it take this alleged plot league
with a huge grain of salt the post
starts with a encode open brain sees the
aftermath of wolf fall and tells to send
Ravens Thurmond and Barrack will survive
almost halfway through the season
Bijan Danny and gang reaches Winterfell
as we know already Satan's minions
except for the one we already know
synthesize partially brakes meeting
Tyrion with the Hound aureus rhenium
with the Hound is the comic relief
John does not seem to know the little
sister he used to know and Arya
surprises and charms him with both her
wit and her calm composure in his scene
of teary eyes the closeness of ginjury
and Arya surprises everybody especially
ser Davos the wingman they while trying
to understand brain John has significant
work although jumbo surprised
oh the Starks he accepts and understands
brain the best brain tells them there's
very short time preparing for the War II
Sam tells John that he is things to
learn from brain instead of learning
parentage at that very moment the fall
of the wall comes into focus that time
and the war council meeting is called
upon later F Qyburn expects Earth's
after her miscarriage and informs her
about normal positions in your gracious
mission Bronson to capture Jaime and
he's going to be traced her say later
for double offer from tyranny in the
previous season Jiyeon reaches the gun
company talks to her Strickland and her
to sell swords G thin sneaks into
captive Yara and rescues her age Jaime
reaches Riverrun
I'm meeting at the Great Hall of NFL
starts with discussion on the war but
soon turns in the discussion about
trusting Cersei trustingly interest and
then on trusting Danny well Danny was
being defended by her friends she waits
to silence them and tells that she's not
come to win the north but instead to
defend the north she apologizes for
father's crimes and tells the
northerners she's seen the night King
and the army of the dead she repeats
John's words in the previous season that
squabbling perrolli over who rules the
throne will push the Seven Kingdoms
endanger the common survival issue
brings people in unison dragon was plans
are discussed John tells how they could
escape from the army of dead in the sea
and make the army of the Dead wait and
buy time from inside an island they
discussed they'll need multiple devices
and approaches to resist and defeat the
army of the Dead with just any one way
not suffice Singh and instead of one
technique water Jang was ruling and
steel and fire all needs to be put into
use Jae Millz Sanjay accompanies fire
hands from mulaney's to join the Great
War in the north the red priests discuss
how the prophecy told of the war against
darkness and the prince princess that
was promised recalling how everybody
fighting for his/her cause will be
reborn but sanjay tells that she's seen
people get back to life and one of them
got back to life six times k berry can't
or moon get rescued by Ed and Gangu
nerve eight Winterfell after the news of
fall with the horses he brought from
Castle black they fast in her journey to
Winterfell
and avoid intersection with the army of
death el post reunion discussion
directions happen in Marin fell Tyrion
Sansa shared their accounts of journey
and Tyrion seems concerned seeing a
different sense that
his experience before who planes
everywhere including a betrayal of serfs
a known from brain another is called
interaction between the women including
sense and Danny about the meth king and
Rhaegar Gilley leagues that Rhaegar
married Liana Brennan's same reveal to
Johnny's parentage John struggles to
accept it but finds overwhelming
evidence about brain to know everything
Ginja begins planning and forging stuff
for war and that are share their ideas
and plans with him john overseas who are
preparations and construction work they
noticed a cold storm slowly approaching
near winter town the gaiden claims that
it's too long for him to continue all of
it in one post and decides to rather
finish it tomorrow he didn't admit that
this might not look very convincing and
tries to justify being the result of it
being his first timely source snows and
he watched the full season so here is
trying to write exactly what he heard
and will offer no answer no explanations
because his source apparently cannot ask
back the person revealing herself to be
the source and we do not want this to
turn out to be an ultimate trap he ends
it with a statement that the show is
just two months to start so get your
detailed answers there when he got some
more time he continued this alleged plot
linked with this the first two episodes
are overall emotional episodes before
the huge catastrophe John and Danny talk
in the Crypt parentage revealed to them
transformation of an array of emotions
in both theory is venerable Jamie
arrived Ximena fell amid welcome and
suspicion he informs the remaining
Italian lynnster forces in Riverrun will
be allies and marching well King's
Landing will not be coming
Qyburn tell Cersei about the progress of
his experiments and about potential
unrest in King's Landing
knowing Jaime is not captured yet Cersei
turns complete mad and s Qyburn to send
a message to urine Sensa seems overjoyed
with the reunions and especially Tyrion
Argan notices that she herself is
excited to be able to be began to read
John the Hound the dragons and Danny
Jamie's really Brienne will lead to an
intimate levels later when FL also gets
prepared strongly for war with arms
armors and defense tactics the trek
Indians Sally take position behind the
trench northern allies take position on
the castle wall and gate every soldier
in highborns are clad in armor and
equipped with generous weaponry urine
starts the trip for attacking minerva
building
company their army will be shown in the
following episodes leader Winterfell at
Kings Road not sure if northern port
arrivals are skipped in being jumps or
if they traveled on the road from King's
Landing brand based on his visions
previously says they'll need to burn the
original place for the White Walkers
were created and melty altar a winter
then he takes shine with him on that
mission and teaches him dragon riding
the fly to this following location near
care she fell spas waterfall her brain
Eddy's vision in season 6 episode 5 of
the white Walker creation Sam and Gilly
discussed the original resolution of the
night King and Sam tells his findings to
brain John again tree sir Davos Potter
Cambrian also talked to Gary near the
forge membrane fills gantry looks
surprisingly familiar looking to her
Danny's pregnancy was revealed near the
end male Sanjay arrives North's parents
several reactions sir Davos once the
executor Ginji gets angry seeing her the
country towards that his previous bad
experiences know Sanjay and Tara's wrath
exposes her feeling for ganger exposed
to hound and Gendry in face of
everybody's opposition brain defenseman
sanjay saying she has a role to play
then is countermand seem to take that
notion in an affirmative look Melisandre
arrives they will have further
interactions later in the season John
and Danny reach the land of always
winter and as they proceed to melt the
altura winter doesn't substitute
commanders appear defending that with
their own groups of the army thirst and
death spread across rule or north as the
night King approaches Winnefeld in a
crowded and poverty distressed winter
town people start getting alerted when
water begins to freeze a here and cry
raises surround the people there amid
tense interactions seminar fell between
several characters including theory
embarrassed and Sansa horns get blown
the army of the Dead has reached the
wolfswood near to winter town cemetery
got a glimpse about the defeat of the
last by walker invasion when the horns
are blown he gets south near the
courtyard and seeing people run in panic
and getting prepared
he goes to brain staring at fire Sam
asked same about the situation and
advice and brain responds calmly that
it's a different enemy for now who are
nearer to Winterfell sam tries to gauge
it but brain looks calm still they will
allow what enemy to chow another for a
while until somebody switches sides
episode three in Episode four is almost
attached and the continuous story
somewhat similar to the continuity of
season 6 episode 5 and season 6 episode
6 as my source thought the episode
demarcation also was not clear in the
scenes she heard in discussion
especially more for the escape scenes
some parts of the scenes fall in later
parts of episode 3 all the rest in
episode 4
there's also perspective she heard that
the war is the near complete reversal of
the battle the bastards in the battle
the bastards protagonists were attacking
meirin fell here they are defending it
the antagonist were defending there and
here they're attacking they'll appear to
help all the golden company will appear
to destroy they'll appeared later the
golden company will appear earlier
they'll acted against the vendor felt
holders the golden company will
eventually act against the invaders in
the battle the bastards the protagonists
thoughtful Hardy and d'von here the
protagonists employ very clever tactics
learned from the battle the bastards and
even after that they lose your
ingredients near Winterfell at Kings
Road of NF L sends representatives to
discuss their motives as Jaime barrister
Outsiders and expandable and the Jamie
knows details about sources playing in
various having good skills in
negotiation they're sent to talk to the
golden company army to understand their
motive to update them about the
impending the army of the dead attack
and to negotiate the negotiation attempt
fails although your own first jokingly
pretends they have come to help he gives
them ultimatum to surrender lights are
the lowest and the army of the dead
seems to be waiting somewhat impatience
similar to strange calmness before storm
when FL changes battle plan meanwhile
the tracking the unsullied are sent to
hide out in middletown in the run
Winnefeld and part of them are pulled
back when negotiation fails svinafell
waits the golan company comes forward
then attacks Winterfell gate when they
are about to break the door the army
that there reaches the battlefield
outside Vener fell into battle begins at
the dead of night monsters fight
monsters but the golden company swiftly
understands their mistake and prays for
shelter
girls came moving the little children
and no people to safety inside the crypt
of NF L intelligently waits for awhile
instead of accepting the golden company
side that they joined the war with horns
blown to the track Indian salad come
forward and join the gun company
attacking the army of the dead in the
beginning they are great The Fearless
unsullied ended the track either jus
coated weaponry decimated the whites in
thousands gaining back support the
golden company as well started getting
back on motion when it seems like the
army that that is going to be manageable
by the joint forces dragon screams a
blue fire starts washing away the
Battlement in its criminate brain enters
a serious evasions evolving the present
past and future among sins in this
vision that masters could remember from
their discussion the nat king raises his
weapon to attack thousands of people
fall to their death jagger museum flames
red and blue fire against the chatter
red cape trembles thousands of commoners
run under the shadow of a dragon the
Valyrian steel blade is projected at
hand of somebody people fight with
swords lit that come back to life with
more of a normal glance invite walkers
collapsed amid buildings breaking down
around them he seems to be here
manipulating or calculating the best
course of series of actions leading to
the feet of the enemies characters had
their own fight scenes and struggles
battling in the army of the Dead all of
them apart from sequences that you
already know like the great arrows
against the dead Giants and White
Walkers the near 214 minute sequence in
the track is burned and fleeing and so
on
additionally we'll see a mindful brain
work stunt centering Raven flocks
distracting Giants walkers and a night
king at late part of the war ghost
action scenes he'll also come saving the
star children from the unearth the dead
John and Danny returned to Winterfell at
the later part of the episode we'll get
to know what happened meanwhile beyond
the wall in the next episode until then
the gorgeous blue versus red flames
producing the otherworldly crystalline
beauty marked their return major parts
of the consecutive transition between
Episode three and four were described in
14 minute sequence before posted
additionally we'll see a rebellion
upcoming is getting filmed at King's
Landing Cersei explains that while
firing Qyburn experiments at commoners
sent that child
near the end stark safe significantly
lost they're losing men are fell most of
the Nights Watch allies Norton Noah is
the betrayed than before including
Glover serving and mannerly are lost
later car starts fail and more months
flee with them Amber's get mostly
destroyed and the number has injured
Nigerians also suffered major damage to
the tracking and saladin some injuries
to jawbone and minor injuries to Riga
Thurmond and some of his free fall
fellows died saving the underage
bannermen particularly Ellis Karstark
Podrick dies allowing safe exit of the
group in a scene reminiscent of the
previous holded or sequence eventually
the golden company gets ransacked and
divided a part of the fleece another
switch sides and fought beside the
northern allies later the Targaryen
campus escapes some back of jolkona
regal they watch back to Steven and fell
burnin it looks a little bit similar to
jurgis funeral pyre from above at the
end of the grid where we will eventually
see Mel Sanchez show powers making
thousands of dead turning back at nights
King in a scene reminiscent reverse of
season 6 episode 5 where his dead enemy
turned to stare ominously their greatest
enemy brain stark
also at the end of the grid for falling
probably in the next episode we'll
eventually see the night King fully on
top of injured Viserion man majority of
his arming at last and the greatest
battle TV has ever seen most of the time
you'll have to look closely at the video
clip to understand what is actually
going on amid all the fog and darkness
and storm most of the discovered gore
and cruelty at the end is currently in
discussion but it was still unbelievable
to them that even after that the episode
is so epic in all proportion he asserted
in the comments that Theon is going to
die bronze arrives the Great War he'll
be a part of Tyrion conspiracy later
they will play out in the last episodes
the first half of the season asserts his
game but the last episode is mainly the
start family's game the Starks get
exasperated at all the trickery becomes
tricky and plays the end game daredevil
he also says that the specific info
marries effectively regains full control
of his former births to such an extent
that the kids work as double agents now
I don't know about you guys you might
believe it as many others do but I just
don't buy it in my opinion it's crafted
fleek based on existing information and
theories and predictions
some of it will likely come true Samuel
not just as it usually is with all the
predictions and theories however I'll
leave it up to you to decide for
yourself whether you want to believe it
or not I don't if you really can wait
for season 8 to come and want to be
spoiled so bad and want to hear legit
leaked go check out my tears that leaked
video and there you'll see one and only
major league that's actually
to happen and as always I hope you guys
enjoyed this video if you did please
make sure to subscribe to our Channel
and I hope to see in the next one peace